whoa whoa whoa whoa welcome new Santa
that's a total world even do this stuff
is awesome
Barbie a pro is the name of this one
well how Pro do you want me to okay
you're right I'm no pesky mommy okay
that was just a fake up I didn't want
you to think that was real okay I don't
know what you want from a game this is
what is this whoa miss me okay okay
that gave me just enough speed yeah I
guess marble or spark fall so Louise you
for Anna okay spike fall with the normal
character
Oh God that took like a hundred tries
oh well somehow we're okay barbar wheels
I'm beginning to think that Santa just
isn't cut out for some of these games
okay there we go hard this is really
hard okay I remember I got more
maneuverability than I think well I can
say that so Marga by play this is what
it said okay Marga liar
whoa wow it's a bit early for the shower
of body parts I didn't know that I
missed okay well well well oh well rude
Markab are 99% death because I know
thanks mark whoa Wow Wow look at that
look at that they tell me in my eye
where to go
did I go to space does it I dumped to
get by all the big arrows pointing down
I would assume this that that's out be
where I need to go
who knows he sings really oh my god I'm
gonna land I'm gonna land on a heavenly
body no [ __ ] - stop jerking around so
much I'm assuming I'm just not supposed
to move this thing just supposed to try
to slow it down
like a central butterfly oh yeah oh my
god
oh look careful oh and plate Kerbal
space probe that that's a little that's
a little odd it's odd that that's there
but it all a lot to see I don't think I
buyed so long as I can survive until I
get to where I need to go maybe I could
sort of wriggle hot what why is that the
amnesia I don't know what that is it was
terrifying I didn't see its face oh god
I hope that's the emmys your monster
okay so the moon is pretty terrifying in
every way wear a helmet going what the
hell is this where the hell am i what
what oh you're kidding me no no my god
that's awesome oh man we haven't played
Tekkit in space in a long time I'm drunk
minecraft aren't so cool obviously my
creation is first a penis always always
a penis my throat is very very raw been
recording a lot today for my trip and
another penis okay good to know and an
even bigger penis in the shape of a
person that's interesting it's gonna
blow me up
he's got blow me up isn't it he's gonna
blow me this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
want to see more happy wheels right now
check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye